our number-3 of day number three here
from the Honda studios in Minneapolis
Minnesota we have our eye on Superbowl
number 52 between the Patriots and the
Eagles and we've had a fun show so far
with Travis Kelce and Greg Olson and
also with DeMarcus Ware who started the
show off and then we also as we had a
Pro Football Hall of Famer and Jerome
Bettis here in our number one JV
smoothes work from media nights on
Monday night we've been reviewing that
and our television only segments it's
also sitting there and they're on our
app where you can also see the latest
co-branded co-produced video between the
show and Funny or Die the replay guide
that holds the monitor on the sidelines
a spotlight cast on the real 12th man of
the National Football League check that
out on our app where you can also vote
on our poll question as well kicking off
our number-3 Chris Brock what do you
have for me on that poll question which
quarterback the top four or highest-paid
assuming Kirk Cousins joins that with do
you want for the 2018 season right now
guys no contest Matt Stafford 47% well
at some point Drew Brees will have to
might join that list and maybe even
Aaron Rodgers Aaron Rodgers on our show
tomorrow and Drew Brees the quarterback
of the man to my left who's joining us
fresh back from Orlando at the Pro Bowl
three-time Pro Bowler defensive end of
the New Orleans Saints and Walter Payton
Man of the Year nominee from New Orleans
Cameron Jordan who's been kind enough to
join us here in person effort agree chat
with us throughout the season on the
phone good to see you sir yeah I
appreciate you having me on of course
right here in person now this is your
hometown correct hey this is my
birthplace okay all right so walk me
through what we talked you know pause
play for the Vikings for 13 years so me
and my siblings were born in Eden
Prairie okay well actually st. Louis
Park if we're gonna be exact okay grew
up and he grew up in Eden Prairie till I
was in first grade mm-hmm and then of
course you know left Minnesota and been
in Arizona ever since okay so your dad
Steve Jordan played 13 years for the
Minnesota Vikings what's your first
football member
um it's not a good memory I mean it was
like being it had it been like an away
game because we were out in the cold and
it was a lot of whining going on
probably from our way to our to our
Godfather about getting hot dogs or
something silly um and then of course
after the game we had gone to the car
and the car like locks had frozen so we
were sort of stuck outside of would be
like Green Bay I'm saying it had it been
it had it been somewhere out so you
probably call it you know mmm yeah I
hadn't been frozen frozen tundra okay so
when did you see when we were growing up
like I want to I want to play football
like my dad did you see that oh no no I
grew up trying to play basketball like
Allen Iverson I mean like everybody else
growing up right uh-huh
and then you something about these wide
shoulders and there's nothing a percent
about it at all nothing point guard ish
about this and you know my dad my dad
jokes about it now but he was that he
was that dad he's like I hate to be that
that father just to make you play
football and then as he dropped me off
and you know in my mind he drove off and
never looked back as I sat there with
these shoulder pads you know he was
clearly right right and so did you try
to be a tight end like your dad of
course not of course not I tried to
fight him on every level I tried to
stall out and not play football at all
like sit on the sidelines while guys are
practicing I tried to be everything you
know I was like I don't want to play
offense at all I tried you know probably
playing linebacker that was not my wave
I ended up being off as a tackle and
then I made myself a defensive end once
I got to like my junior in high school
okay because the the story that I heard
is that your dad asked you if you wanted
to play tight end and your response as a
child was one as I live was was no thank
you sir yeah something that well there I
love you I I have to decline this notion
no you said why would I want two people
to hit me when I can be the one
delivering the head that would make
perfect sense since you know sounds like
a count Berkeley guy nobody wants to you
know nobody wants to get bullied so okay
you know why not be the bully I like it
Cameron Jordan of the Saints here the
field and you know speaking of family
I noticed this this photograph from the
Pro Bowl in Orlando I love this picture
and we'll put it on the screen here
that's you on the ground there a baby
chef who's that young lady that's right
there oh yeah Adam Schefter his daughter
right so is that that still is that his
daughter yes Dylan shefter nice right
she does not mean she walks that's why
she tweeted it out
does she trying to get information on
the Saints your dad is that what's going
on say right look I was trying to uh I
was just trying to see if she had any
inside information on you know this
upcoming draft you know through her dad
but knows she was a cute little kid that
just came up and you know that's cool
shut off question how was the how was
the Pro Bowl for you it was good um you
know you have first two Pro Bowls in
Hawaii
Orlando's a family experience yeah who
is it part of your posse and the
passport to fun there oh we were deep
this year I'd like to say you know mom
was there dad was there brother sister
and now as we're getting older their
counterparts okay um you know my better
half was there are two kids okay
so how old are your two kids I got a two
year old or one year old oh so we're not
they're not they're not magic mounting
or anything like that I mean we took
home I ain't I mean you know she was
like all the love Disneyland or Disney
World and I was like all right they're
not gonna remember any of this right but
I'm not here to argue I'm only here to
to just to serve understood so now that
did you go to the Pro Bowl with your dad
as well he went to six yeah I figured I
had to make at least one or two of them
I don't I can't bring anything I meant
when he went to the Pro Bowl did you go
to Hawaii what I'd like to say I did I
was four when he you know right yeah I'd
like to pull a memory you know there is
a beach memory I don't know if it's
Hawaii memory certainly in the ocean it
certainly wasn't when the car doors were
locked because they were frozen that's
for damn sure we're not in there I'll
tell you that so I don't know the
delicate way to ask this question I mean
that building that's right there behind
us is it she's been playing in it don't
worry about it
that's cool that's what I'm asking you
um last time we played it there I mean
the first time we played there just
there wasn't the results that we were
looking for I know that and that but
that that seems like two years ago
pretty much like week one right that was
week one those different quarterback
that was a different running back it's
different circumstances and a different
outcome and you know I had pretty much
held our I had came back the second half
and played an astounding second half
just to trick it off so what would you
tell him would you tell the kid would
you tell him that he had an interception
the third quarter marks will be here
right and all those young young guns in
the secondary have been terrific right
and that's the back end with your front
end that makes the Saints a much more
formidable team with Drew Brees at the
trigger with those two guys behind him
in in the running backs but what do you
tell Marcus Williams after that I mean I
mean there's sort of easy enough to say
you know he's clearly had the passion
for the game I mean everything that you
could possibly see in that play whether
it was he had arrived too early or you
know it's easy just to try and consoled
him just saying you know you also got us
back in the game with this interception
for you and made a pivotal play don't
let it keep you down only let it
motivate you and now you know you might
want to stealth social media for a
little bit but everybody who knows
Marcus Williams as a person and as a
player knows he has nothing but the
highest integrity for this game and that
being said you know pre the CBA you know
safety would have knocked knocked the
hell out of Stefon Diggs and you know we
wouldn't have even had this discussion
different rules different times hmm so
um what do you think's gonna happen in
that building on Sunday give me your
best guess here oh knowing what it's
like to take on I think in a very Brady
esque fashion somehow he's going to pull
this one off it's going to probably come
down to the fourth quarter and if they
go to overtime and they're gonna double
overtime does that equal a tie
can we just for go they if this thing
goes
this thing goes to double overtime that
I'd sign a piece of paper for that right
now I don't know if the players would
right I mean can we just push this on to
next year and we'll just settle it in
Atlanta we'll just because I would ask
you what it's like taking on New England
but we already established week one
feels like two seasons ago so we have to
be the same damn thing right but what
what do you think Philadelphia needs to
do well what did I get Sean Payton or at
least uh Dennis Allen banging your heads
prior to taking on New England about
taking on Brady they've got all the
tools to do so you talk about the way
their second heir has been playing we
talked about their D line
re-establishing that line of scrimmage
we with Fletcher Cox with Vinny curry
with you know Chris long Brandon Graham
and even though young Barnett I mean
they've got all the tools to collapse a
pocket and harass Brady enough to
hopefully you know reopen that wound on
his hand
mm-hmm that would be the goal right - of
course not injure him but just reopen
those stitches mm-hmm maybe get him out
there and see who's behind him who is
behind him mm-hmm
I mean they traded off crap Filosa
rights warrior Oh actually who's capable
by the way that is capable capable is
like the word solid right there's it's
infused with infused with a little bit
of critique he's capable called you a
capable defensive line I am capable of
doing a lot of things I'm capable of
wrecking games I'm capable you're solid
at knocking balls now solid now you
didn't you didn't do the matumbo finger
that we tried to I know because I really
want the sack I really want I really
want to make a four so a pump fake
mm-hmm um but of course you know some
Jets game with apparently five you
knocked them all down right I know and
so just at least one matumbo for where
he start pump faking just one times I
could really get there you know right Oh
messing up my set yeah no no look you
you had a heck of a day against the Jets
that day that was for damn sure I
thought I had an interception landed
outside
pounds come on I needed that two
sections in a year is great and do you
think do you think breeze is returning
Oh buddy Oh what happened you're just
looking at yourself you know you still
batten them down hey when one went back
to Bryce petty for an incompletion see
that particularly to piss you off do you
think breezes returning yeah of course
oh not even a question right yeah I mean
I would say you know I'd be sort of
weird about it had he not said hey I'm
coming back for sure so I just believed
him
okay you know um if both sides say
you're coming back for sure I just
assume he's you know okay
yes so you're not concerned about that
whole sort of thing nope okay good
what are you doing for the rest of the
week here that's a phenomenal question
um whatever has been laid out for me
I've proposed the schedule I just don't
know it by heart
oh really yeah luckily I got a
phenomenal publicist okay Beck's
appreciate you why you're given a little
shout out for publicist we always
appreciate that right do you want to go
bowling with us time yeah
eight o'clock yeah trying to come home
with us yeah is he free we got one guy
who's who's who's completely doesn't
have his gear Jerome Bettis said he
could not Bowl because he doesn't have
his own personal bowling ball and his
shoes here I've always wanted my own
like like um glove is that what I've
always liked pre-tape the knees like let
you know I'm ready about this well make
this happen yeah come on when you are in
Los Angeles please come by no Joe our
show studio they're really really always
appreciate our conversations yeah invest
in the great MA all pro season man
Congrats on that Cameron Jordan is here
on the Rich Eisen show check him out at
cam Jordan 90 for Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience